all right uh vial is our I don't know
how do you say your name sir
yeah ma'am I'm sorry Yael okay Yael how
can I assist okay so I have this product
that I've been trying to find and
basically it's discontinued and I am
dying for this product and I'm like I'm
manufacturing this thing there's a huge
need in my community for this and I'm
very passionate about it and I want to
do it but I don't know the first thing
from business and they have no money
since our data okay have you done any
investigation as to what it will cost to
manufacture it yourself is it something
I can do in your basement no okay all
right so you would have to quote hire a
factory unquote to build this thing
right
okay oh I don't know how much it's going
to cost but if I really I really want to
get it out there it's going to be a
hundred thousand yeah which I can do
right now obviously obviously so um what
what area without getting into the
details baby product a baby product okay
do you know anyone around the industry
that creates baby products no I would I
know
I don't not anybody can create I know
break oh but I have no connection to
great go that's what I mean like do you
have a connection to anybody in that
world that's what I was asking
um yeah because I was thinking maybe we
sell your idea to them to go do is that
is the best thing to do maybe and maybe
you just take a licensing fee off of it
after you can maybe you get the idea
patented or something right even the
patents is going to be ten thousand
dollars yeah what is your household
income uh thirty P okay all right well
here's the thing you don't know business
you don't know the baby manufacturing
business you don't know the
manufacturing business this is a real
opportunity for you to go bankrupt if
you go like borrow a hundred thousand
dollars and now go into space go into a
space you don't know anything about only
to find out
that you violated six product laws and
you get a suit I mean there's all kinds
of crap you could trap you can step into
that'll rip your leg off here okay so I
just don't I don't want you to do that
uh there's no pot I mean do you what
would the product be made of a kind of
material movie plastic and metal locos
be plastic a little a metal okay if you
can find someone in your area that has a
plastic molding shop maybe you can talk
them into working with you to develop
the prototype and let them only let them
own a piece of it because they've got
the ability to do the design and if you
can get a prototype then you could you
can get your patent done and maybe go to
some stores and get some sales just by
walking into the local Babies R Us and
going hey if you had ten of these on the
shelf could you sell them and they would
go yeah and they would order that thing
so I don't I mean that it's a real
problem to create a physical product
come up with a patent money come up with
the mold money to do the prototype and
do all of that on $30,000 a year very
difficult to do I do not have a great
idea for you unless you can find
somebody to come alongside you and walk
with you that takes part of the deal and
you give up part of it to get it done
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh